you know he's such a loving boy really
loving energetic life and soul of the
party
a grieving mother at her son's grave
Stacy O'Donnell's son Ty was stabbed to
death by his abusive girlfriend but
court delays a covered backlog and a
canceled first trial last September due
to the Barrister's strike meant they
ended up waiting nearly two years for a
trial
I'd spent months worrying about what
might happen overthinking different
scenarios about how the trial might play
out and then it came to September and
you know I hadn't been sleeping all year
I've been waking up I kid you not for
five o'clock every day waking up anxiety
really going through it it's not until
the trial was passed that I can actually
feel how much weight has been lifted but
it's not just victims and their families
who are harmed by these delays also
waiting months if not years for their
day in court are the defendants some of
whom can spend that entire time behind
bars with latest figures showing that
the number of people being held on
remand is at its highest point for 50
years
a defendant being held in prison before
their trial shouldn't spend more than
six months on remand but Emma Lewis
represented one client who was jailed
for 18 months only to be found innocent
same day that the jury went out to
consider their verdicts they returned a
not guilty verdicts because it was clear
he was not guilty and then he was just
released with no support nothing we had
to have him assess because we were
concerned he became very introvert he
would struggle to speak given the
backlog the Justice committee has called
on the government to review the law
around renowned prisoners but they
rejected several key recommendations
these are people who've not been
convicted of anything and a percentage
of them reasonable percentage of them
will ultimately not be convicted
statistically
a Ministry of Justice spokesperson said
remanded defendants are now waiting 15
weeks for trial on average and we are
investing almost half a billion pounds
to reduce the outstanding caseload in
the courts
for Stacy the guilty verdict is late but
welcome and it means she can finally
prioritize the biggest fight of all
coming to terms with the loss of her
beloved Son Rachel venables Sky News